I'm a blend of a computer scientist an
organic chemist and
um
I I work right now in in force field
development and I'll explain that uh
during this presentation
um and for the last 12 years I've been
in Python I start off in like early
python 2.3 and I decided to use Python
for this project too and you'll see how
kind of wrap my my head around this and
getting something
off the ground
um so I wanted to start off very very
simplistically uh there's this molecule
on the left hand side here
um does anyone know what this molecule
is called
if you had to say the English or sorry I
just uh
don't know
um yeah let me know once you've got that
shirt again and I'll bring the screen up
sure uh this thing
yeah I'll monitor the comments so don't
worry about it just you can just share
your full screen yeah
sorry
um
okay so uh did anyone have a response
or maybe they saw it
um a lot of people call this uh asorbic
acid and like a lot of scientists know
what this is used in the common
um when you're in the field you you know
what this name is and you know how to
use it and apply it but the common
General people it doesn't really ring a
bell uh so if I was talking about
ascorbic acid to someone that works in
like a marketing thing they have no clue
but if I change the name into what
people regularly call it which is
vitamin C
uh it rings Bell to everyone and so
um
but there exists now two names for the
same chemical compound one that is more
easily recognized from one group of
people and one that's recognized for a
very subset so there's like a general
and then there's also a very subset
community
um and in the 1980s uh when you try to
record these chemical compounds into the
computer it wasn't very intuitive in how
to actually record something like this
into the computer and actually like
create a database and so uh this
language is Smiles was developed which
is a 1D language to kind of represent
and condense down this information until
1D strength and uh the language was
developed as an organic chemist to be
intuitively to just write this on their
keyboard into the computer so if I even
draw the molecule you can just write the
string directly
um
so what I did is uh I studied Smiles for
for a long time and um
as I started to uh analyze databases I
realized I needed a reference index for
all these different types of functional
groups that were actually useful to
people
um and for me a lot of the chemicals
that are in my daily life is what I read
off of the ingredients for for anything
really
um and so I figured that'd be a good
starting point for keeping a reference
index
uh and so that's that's what I did and
so
[Music]
um
the the thing is is that
um there's a lot of different types of
chemicals in the world and uh
for me I I don't know what all of them
are and so if I wanted to expand and
look into chemical infinity and chemical
space I needed to have a good reference
index
um but very diverse uh and for me right
as an organic chemist I'm I'm siled into
what I know and so I needed to expand
that out and so I started reaching out
to a lot of my scientist friends or
Engineers even just like the regular
people in my daily life
um about what chemicals they they have
in in their life and what do they use
and I can use this as like an index
um and so a couple of examples that I I
kind of hit is like uh in the top left
here I've got the interstellar space so
these are all the common molecules found
in space
um the language is very old and so
they've got some like very weird rules
to how that languages can kind of
constructed or how they label the
molecules and even then the molecules
are very weird in space uh there's a
very popular
um recreational drug Cannabis sativa so
um if you go to like a medical
dispensary you'll see on the the back of
the package there's like 11 terpenes but
for me
um I've gone through this 6 000 years of
history with Carlton Turner's paper and
then I have 425 ingredients of cannabis
centiva and 101 terpenes in my list and
so I have this index for what's in there
um I
over here and on the left hand side I
really started pushing this into like
you you have the Russian Ukrainian war
and you have nerve toxic agents
developed during the Cold War from the
Russians and so
um but it's not clear in what nerve
toxic agents are being used to kill or
what they use to approve so I've gone
through the books of like honig or Dr
mirzano's account when they defect it
and the chemical groups that were in
there have recorded it so now we have
this index too of what toxic agents
um I had a lot of uh female co-workers
and they they complain a lot about birth
control so I always hear about birth
control a lot
um and so uh one of the problems they
have is when they keep switching birth
control and the excipients used in those
in those drugs and what they're allergic
to or things that kind of like mess
around with their hormones so I started
recording like
what molecules are used in these oral
contraceptives and then how do these
people kind of respond to it and
similarly with narcotics too so
um these lists became very expansive and
I I recorded around
3500 in there so now we have this
reference index
so I needed to organize all this data
that was kind of coming in and
um to be honest I I didn't exactly know
how but python was something I was uh
that's what I was taught data structures
and so I was kind of uh going back to
some familiarity there
um the root note I kind of said is
global chem so I I just set up a very
like
basic node architecture structure where
you have like all your different types
of nodes and each node
um is essentially like for for the first
one let's say narcotics so uh in the USA
they've got a list of five scheduled
um lists of Narcotics and varying their
degree of
um severity and schedule one is kind of
like the the hardcore like okay these
drugs should not be on the market so uh
what I did is I wrote The Python object
schedule one and inside I wrote the list
of smiles and uh the common chemical
name or how they report it uh uh and so
each node is its resource and inside the
the methods for each
node are essentially get the smiles and
another language gets smarts which is a
rejects pattern batching
um and so I organized it kind of like
this this directory structure and you'll
you'll see it if you go inside the code
um
later on and this is uh where I'm trying
to like abstract the classifications of
these molecules so like uh I came and
came up with its own basic route of like
food cannabis sexual Wellness War
narcotics there's more in there like
your skin and uh environment materials
and the list goes on
um and then I distributed this so I made
it pip installable and people can access
the network or use this data however
they see fit and so over the last year
or so it's been climbing at 160k
Thousand downloads and then still on its
own right and kind of living a little
bit on its own for a bit
um so for me though uh I wanted to do a
little bit more understanding so a
little bit of a different of kind of
like a pseudoscience aspect of what I
could do with this data
um and so this is where we're gonna uh
change a little bit into understanding
what a molecule really is
um so
uh you take
you take a molecule
and you can abstract it out into certain
features and features that describe like
the molecular geometry and how it
behaves to other molecules around it
um
so uh in the world of quantum chemistry
and molecular mechanics there is
um what they do is they basically uh
predict
geometry using quantum mechanics and
they match the quantum to
using a molecular mechanics model and
then using some parameters to kind of
Define like okay these are the
these are the numbers to record like how
this molecule behaves and there's a lot
of different types of equations in life
and for now I'm married to this one so
this is the charm uh equation and you
can kind of see here that the
uh the molecule can be abstracted out
into seven different features
um the bonds meaning this is the
um this is uh describing the the force
constant and the distance between two
atoms the angle which is the angle
between three atoms the dihedral which
is the angle between this atom and that
one and it's like 3D space as it's
rotate the improper is like when
something is bent
out of its plane and it's the torsion
when it's bent out of its plane
um urea badly is a uh when you have a
three atom system and then the one to
three interactions between them as they
kind of collide you kind of put like a
pseudo bar
coulombic is point charges between the
atoms and the Leonard Jones which is
um my thesis
and uh which is kind of describing the
van der waals uh or it's been shown to
kind of describe the van der waals which
is your repulsive and attraction forces
uh repulsion year 12 and 6. so
I read my thesis if you're interested in
Leonard gems
um so I kind of want to describe like
what what that means so like let's let's
take a bond and how do we actually
record this into the computer
um so let's look at the theory and then
let's apply it into the computer
uh
you have a methyl carbon here and let's
say you have a oxygen so an alcohol here
they both have a hydrogen so hydrogen is
a base category and we all understand
that is but these hydrogens are attached
to different heteroatoms and oxygen and
a carbon which and they're different
types because they're in different
environments and this environment I'm
trying to show is like for uh for uh for
a methyl hydrogen
it kind of protrudes out of the radius
of the carbon here and so this this
hydrogen actually sticks a little bit
out whereas like a polar hydrogen like
this this one with this oxygen sits
inside of the oxygen radius at 0.22
angstroms so they're they're very
different in terms of like where that
hydrogen is and how accessible it is to
something else and we record this as
saying that like okay previous carbon
and this hydrogen we call this as
cg331 which is our nomenclature for kind
of describing what this atom type is
with this this type of hydrogen hda3
um and then we record this polar
hydrogen as like one polar group
hydrogen and then this one is the three
aliphatic group hydrogen
um and we recorded around roughly 158
atom types across a lot of different
elements and so our atom type engine
from what I know is the largest in the
world
um
so now that we have this atom type
engine we have a way to describe this
type of stuff uh we can kind of get more
acute information of understanding
molecules in larger sets
um
so
what I did is uh
um
all right
our dictionary that we wrote
is written in smiles and
I needed to process it through that
software to predict these parameters for
what
um they are and kind of look at the
performance of far force field
and so to do that I had to take a small
string and convert it into our language
and so uh
and another talk maybe I'll I'll go into
this because it's a little bit more
advanced is
um building this in Python and then
having this workflow where I basically
take
large sets of small strings and then I
pass it through our c plus code and then
I get back out
um
the atom types and then all their
different parameters and I abstract that
into a database uh
the
the force field that we have so we
recorded 158 atom types and if
those atom types are not like if we have
a molecule that we haven't seen before
and we need to predict new atom types
for it we kind of have a penalty score
where we kind of like okay
um we can estimate new parameters for
this molecule based on how similar it is
to something else and the penalty score
is attributed to how different something
is and where these parameters were
abstracted from so we can actually use
that penalty score to start exploring
chemical space because
if we have a reference index for what
we've seen before we can start looking
for things that we haven't
um and that's what I did so uh
I looked into the chemical Universe a
bit and I needed to find a molecule to
parametize which is what we do in our
group
um and so I place the
I put all the molecules through and then
I took the probability distribution of
those molecules with the penalty score
on the x-axis on the y-axis you can kind
of see like okay these are
around 750 molecules here are kind of
having a penalty score of zero which
meaning that we've seen these all before
and we have parameters for that
um the rare ones as we kind of move past
100 and the score goes up to Infinity so
there was no barrier there uh
the you can start to pick up patterns
that you haven't seen before this
pattern right here is called a diphilane
and I haven't actually seen that before
because this ring system is is it's new
to me so I've looked at a lot of
different types of drugs and chemicals
and this is kind of what we do and
design we look at new fragments someone
also tattooed to my arm
um
so then I wanted to to kind of expand
this into something a little bit more uh
pseudosciency for for fun aspect and the
reason being was to to kind of help its
marketing Ploy because
um
you know I feel like when you have a lot
of this data it's it's very hard to to
visualize and plot like exactly what's
going on but you can also start to do
some more fun things when you have this
data uh so I wrote this kind of like
um
workflow in Python with D3 to get this
this chord diagram and how this chord
diagram Works uh or this particular one
is that all the atom type languages or
all the all our atom types that are from
the global common universe is a node
here on the graph and then each
uh point so each color represents a
different type of bond or not Bond um
relationship between the atom type so if
this atom type exists with another one
so I just wanted to check their presence
and how frequent two different atom
types kind of show up together
uh
uh so what I did here is then I looked
at the counts of how much two atom types
exist and then that kind of correlates
to the thickness of the line and when
you look at this
when you follow this plot you can kind
of see this hga one and it's hga 5
following the pink
I was looking at this for a long time
um
the the alkene proton is hga 5 and hga1
is a hydrogen sitting off of a
um carbon so
the or an alphotic carbon so we can kind
of like start to abstract like a very
basic question that like okay maybe
alkenes are very common alkanes are very
common which we already know but we
start to kind of like as we sample more
of the universe we can pick up on atom
types that are more common that show up
and start looking at different atom
types that maybe are not so it helps us
kind of extort exploring some things
um
a more
so I I wanted to start really expanding
this workflow into something bigger and
bigger because uh there is a data set
called the enemy database which sits at
around 22 billion right now and they're
expanding their smallest string so it's
written in Smalls and it has their
they're getting up to about a billion
per month uh with the whole Russian
Ukrainian War they've kind of paused
because their servers are gone down a
bit
um
so I needed to expand my workflow into
handling larger and larger sets of data
and so the first step is like okay can I
tack on a million molecules and pass it
through our force field and then start
looking at uh more
um Bond relationships so what are the
most common bonds uh and so I pushed one
million molecules through
and I looked at just the bond so not
like if they exist with each other but
how frequently those types show up
and when I was looking at this plot I
could kind of change the curvature and
kind of come up with a relationship to
see where the density of like some
certain like atom types would be and I
was looking at this
and I could see that the cg2 r62 and the
cg2 are six seven so these kind of
showed like directly within this this
density here and these two are like a
Benzene carbon and an azeline Bridge
carbon so something like right here
um azalean complexes I've seen more and
more showing up as a common ring
fragment if you look at the
rings and drugs paper with
um and rings and drugs are the common
ring systems that pass FDA phase three
trials uh
azalean shows up more and more because
it's a trending molecule and so it's
something that I kind of keep in the
background as well but like maybe I
might need to use an asylum complex
um so then this project grew in its own
way so as I as I started expanding more
into just
um plotting things and showcasing it to
people
and um kind of just working through my
thesis here uh I I was expanding out
into a lot of different social media
platforms
um Hacker News Indie hackers and Reddit
was my primary primary one
um those plots received a lot of General
attention because people could just play
around with it so that's what kind of
gained some more traction
um
duh
the idea was that the chemical list can
come from anywhere and it can be backed
by anyone that's like within their own
Community
um providing information to me so I can
write the molecules to them and so
initially it started off with just a
network of graduate students that I
found through Twitter and so
um
through like five or six different
universities around the world we I just
taught smiles to people and we we've
been writing
um postdocs from different universities
and my own have like helped contribute
and guidance of the development and then
I have
you know some undergrads and I have
people with no degrees so people that
have just reached out that are like okay
I have I work in landscaping and these
are the chemicals I use for that or this
is what I
um I work in hair styling or
um that type of stuff so
yeah I think one of the popular ones was
like nail polish and hair styling and
and that stuff
um and I needed to also establish this
in such a way that it was like building
kind of a community so more and more
people were reaching out and I needed
this to
to like as more and more data was coming
in and I didn't have enough time to kind
of like work through everything uh I
just realized I needed to establish this
kind of like body to to oversee this so
we were kind of uh establishing this
this non-profit and it's just through
like keeping this data
uh open and free so and we as the people
kind of like help govern what that data
is and how to help regulate this
dictionary
uh
I with the GitHub repo I backed it with
the whole git coin Grant which means I
could just
funnel the the money into the repo so
I'm still kind of working through what
that means but I don't exactly know that
the workings of that
um but what is next so the the idea is
that
um
there there's so many different types of
rules for each list so there was rules
for materials rules for environment
rules for how people came up with like
um just even talking about vitamins so
like I I realized as I was trying to
write my own rulebook it was getting
kind of crazy
so what I started doing is I was just
building a seek to seek model of
undefined rules and coming up with kind
of this General
um maybe
seek to seek model that could kind of
like do the prediction of the common
chemical name to the smiles or back
again
uh and so I'm still kind of working
through that and that's a project that
I'm hoping to kind of complete next year
uh more Folker have been joining and
backing the projects there was an MPL
license a Mozilla public license
attached to it and I won't get into the
legality of that but
um
it has been cool because the data could
come also from Academia or industry and
people that use this data for their own
companies or something
um it's just built on some transparency
so everyone's using this and then
um kind of help partner or support it
and so one of the
recent supports we got is this pot coin
cryptocurrency for backing on the on the
Cannabis list which is very relevant to
them
um so the Project's grown a lot and you
know I've met a lot of wonderful people
that I didn't think I would meet before
and they've they taught me a lot about
different stuff and so I feel like a lot
of my science has matured
uh to get to this point so the last
thing I I do want to leave you with
is I have a demo here
and then I change the the language at
the top to something that's more
intuitive to a chemist or someone that's
like basic so like you wouldn't have to
know our language and you can kind of
look at this and follow the lines
yourself
um and read the different types of nodes
that should be kind of easier for you
don't know where to uh
maybe I'll send it to Sean I've I've
edited the chat so our audience members
can actually click on that link and then
follow to them cool
um and that is it if anyone like to ask
any questions
great well thank you so much Sal for the
very nice talk I I like to see uh it's a
very novel and very fruitful Endeavor to
try and map out a navigable space of
knowledge craft or chemicals right yeah
excellent
um so there are a couple questions in
chat I'll just pick one out first uh
uh all right the first question would be
um I'll start with Darius
uh Dario is asking are certain molecules
duplicated in different lists if so can
you look up in which lists it is or
industry it is used when you know the
name
so you're asking are different molecules
recorded differently in different lists
right oh wait
yeah so
um I have a partner on this or she's
helped curating me as patina and she has
decided
um she wants to standardize
that part
um we we originally kind of kept it as
like uh
as like okay how it's recorded is how
will how we'll keep it and there's
functionality built into the code so
when you fetch like a molecule
um you can see like like if you fetch it
by Smiles you can see which nodes it
come from and then which List It
corresponds to but for the actual
standardization we still haven't decided
that yet
um but there is functionality for
getting that information built into the
code
yeah yeah absolutely okay interesting
well thanks thanks for that answer
um
it's another question which um I think I
think is quite quite hilarious so I'll
just bring it out one screen again so
Stephen Stephen's asking so so would
your research help in designing
something like a super read yeah so
that's actually in the the works because
the the canvas industry
um
now has a reference index and so like uh
basically you can do like fingerprinting
and you can start predicting new
different THC compounds based on that
and then like playing around with it the
the thing is is uh
is the chemical composition from the
phenotype
which needs to be regulated
um
and that has a lot of effect so on
on different users uh more than people
think so
yeah I feel like if you know the
chemical composition plus the Terrapins
then yeah you could do what you need to
do